[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this is
google's new budget phone the pixel 6a
we knew this was coming i've had my
hands on this phone for a little over a
week now and i have my thoughts sort of
summarized into one major thought which
is
there's a lot of competition in this
budget phone space now
and this phone
isn't the obvious hands-down winner that
it might have once been but this year
more than ever
i think the primary reason for that
comes down to the display
and i'll explain what i mean so what
we're getting with this google budget
phone is and this may sound familiar a
new chip the exact same one that's in
the flagship models the same software
experience as the flagships but just
with some cheaper hardware surrounding
it you know kind of like the iphone se
but google's version and so the price
here is 449 dollars
it really looks just like any other of
the pixel 6 phones i mean that's the one
thing i like about the whole lineup
they're unmistakably pixel you've got
the two-tone colors the camera bar
across the middle is recognizable as a
pixel from a mile away the only
difference here is well it's a slightly
new color this one is a sage green
but also the camera bump isn't as tall
so it's a bit slimmer it doesn't
protrude out of the phone as much so i
don't really use the ledge as a grip as
much anymore as i used to on the other
phones everything else though on the
outside is pretty much the same it's got
the aluminum rails same power and volume
buttons on the right side with a notch
between them
the speakers and the slightly off center
usb c port at the bottom
it's all back on the inside though this
phone is ip67 not ip68 and there is no
wireless charging
that to me was kind of a bummer i know
we're probably saving a couple dollars
here but this phone still has a glass
back and
i don't know if you've used wireless
charging before then it's kind of worth
noting that this one won't have it and
then also the pixel 5a had a headphone
jack this pixel 6a
does not have a headphone jack so again
if you use that then that's another
thing to note but really around the
front here is where the pixel 6a
actually most reflects its price so
we've got a 6.1 inch flat 1080p oled
display at 60 hertz with a top center
hole punch and an in-display fingerprint
reader
visually it's an okay display it's
decently sharp with good color and it
gets bright enough to support hdr and
not totally suck outdoors but also it
has some pretty serious off-axis
rainbowing and the auto brightness is a
little finicky
and the fingerprint reader is definitely
slow it's on the slow side just like it
was on the pixel 6 and 6 pro now this
may be forgivable stuff in a budget
phone we've seen stuff like that around
this price but what really takes it a
tear down for me is the 60 hertz
specifically because
this one
feels slow actually let me be more
specific so
this is a 60hz display there's lots of
other 60hz displays in phones out there
having a tensor chip which is a
relatively high-end chip inside should
mean that the phone still feels fast and
it still opens apps pretty fast and
that's still mostly true here
but for whatever reason the
responsiveness and the actual smoothness
of the display this is not smooth so i
think this is absolutely going to be one
of those things that you either feel and
notice right away or you just never
notice i think there's a lot of people
who are going to be looking to get a
pixel 6a that are coming from an older
phone coming from a budget phone coming
from other 60 hertz phones and this will
probably feel right in line but even
amongst these 60 hertz phones i feel
like this is one of the choppiest ones
and now i've also recently come from a
world of 120 hertz and 165hz flagship
phones and gaming phones and that's not
the normal place a 6a buyer will come
from but the second you experience 120hz
on a phone you are way more likely to
notice the dropped frames in animations
all the time even at 60hz literally just
scrolling around pulling down the
notification shade opening and closing
apps normal stuff is just constantly
slightly choppy now the funny thing is
it's hard for me to show you this stuff
on camera this is a 30 fps video and
these things are happening somewhere
between 30 and 60 fps but yeah this is
one of those things where i bet if you
get to see a 6a in a store or try it out
then you'll feel what i'm talking about
but it really is a feel thing and this
is purely coming from my decade of phone
testing experience this one feels choppy
now depending on who you are even all of
this might be acceptable knowing still
that things are technically launching
quickly and you're not lagging out and
you're actually launching apps at normal
speed
but i'm combining all this with my
knowledge of what i've just seen happen
with the last year of pixels which is
they haven't aged particularly
gracefully so i've seen what happened to
six and the six pro
and i worry about how this fun will age
considering how it feels now is
guaranteed three years of software
updates but what does this phone look
like in three years now the good thing
is everything else about the pixel here
is exactly what you'd expect the same
software experience as the big brothers
with material u google's widgets and
dynamic colors and stock apps like the
calculator and settings and camera et
cetera google's smartest features are
all here like assistant call screening
is awesome live translate and the
sorcery that is basically instant speech
to text everywhere in this phone thanks
to the tensor chip they're all so good
the haptics are also pretty good which
is great to see in a budget phone along
with the stereo speakers here really the
only variables that could have come up
as a surprise potentially would be
battery or cameras so pixel 6a's battery
is about 4 400 milliamp hours
and it turned out to be fine there were
some concerns because oh it's a tensor
chip it's a higher end chip uses more
power maybe in a smaller phone that's
bad but
turns out 60 hertz kind of balances that
out so i had pretty good battery life i
was just mildly annoyed by not having
wireless charging but then there's the
cameras so with the camera unlike the
previous pixels this does not share the
same cameras as the more expensive
brothers the 6 and the 6 pro instead it
has a downgraded 12 megapixel camera
setup for both the standard and the
ultra wide which might look
disappointing on paper but
this is the old sony imx 363 sensor
which some of you nerds will already
recognize is the same exact sensor that
was in the pixel 5 and the same that was
in the pixel 4 and the pixel 3 and the
pixel 2 in other words this is an older
smaller low resolution sensor but it is
also absolutely a tried-and-true great
smartphone camera because of google's
computational photography chops so i
really appreciated that even with the
lower number you know with the tensor
chip processing things happening really
fast the shots that come out of this
camera are crisp contrasty and confident
just like they were with the older
pixels the colors are on point too not
too much over processing happening and
there is not too much fringing at the
edges either with close-up subjects and
the dynamic range and how it handles
highlights is a plus
so i mean it's easy to see why they
stuck with this for so long and the fact
is this is still easily a top two budget
smartphone camera easy it also has the
ultra wide that the iphone se doesn't
have and it takes decent looking 4k
videos up to 60fps
these cameras are like pizza sure
they're not super new and groundbreaking
there's nothing that would impress you
about them on paper but they get the job
done in a design that you can dress up
like a ninja turtle if you get the right
dbrand skins
you know the ones linked in the
description the conversation around the
pixel 6a is probably the most
interesting when you consider the
competitors just the other phones that
you could get for 450 and there's some
other really good ones
so to make it easy i think you should
get the pixel 6a if you value
the google software experience
those features
and or the camera
way over everything else but if that's
not you you could get a samsung galaxy
a53 for a hundred bucks less and that's
going to have 120hz display that has
expandable storage or you could get a
nothing phone which i just reviewed
which has all those quirky lights
features on the back but that's also got
a much bigger
much much smoother 120hz display and all
their features
you could even get an iphone se if you
wanted to which yes is gonna be
a 60 hertz single camera setup with a
smaller battery but that's also a
flagship chipset that's also wireless
charging and that's also let's be real
it's an iphone which is enough of a
feature for some people and then there's
some nord phones and some pocophones and
some moto g's all with their own merits
so yeah pixel 6a turns out is really all
about the google software experience
and the camera for the price that's
where it excels but yeah if you're
shopping around keep your eyes open
because there's a bunch of good stuff
and while
good phones aren't getting cheap
cheap phones are still very much getting
good
there you have it that's been it thanks
for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]